[Applause]
we are the beginning
of a new era for the future exploration
and commercialization of space
first it will be the moon and from there
mars and the rest of the solar system
i've always been fascinated by space
exploration
but at the same time troubled
by its multiple implications
historically
human exploration has led to an
aggressive
exploitation of people land
and resources this ongoing
colonization process has shaped the
unfair world
we live in today so how can we make sure
we stop perpetuating the same old
colonial patterns
when i was appointed artist in residence
at the european space agency
i thought it was a unique opportunity to
make a bold statement
to rethink as human beings what do we
really need to take with us
on this space journey and perhaps
even more importantly what you will
leave behind
as a privileged white male individual
born and raised in europe i grew up in a
world
where western art science and technology
are presumed superior over
every other form of knowledge
however visiting many museums
and their vast collections products of
our colonial heritage i was introduced
to a wide range of cultures
and unique ways to understand the world
we live in
humanity's greatest achievement was not
landing on the moon
but our cultural diversity the rituals
beliefs and knowledge woven within it
this rich legacy does not belong in the
past
but is very much alive sometimes even
thriving
we rarely talk about cultural
ethical or even spiritual matters
when discussing space exploration but
i believe it's precisely culture that
will give
us a purpose in the future through my
artistic practice
i'm learning to appreciate multiple
cultural dimensions without the
nostalgia
or condescension that historically
has been projected upon these cultures
their knowledge and their significance
[Music]
this is kim kum hua korea's most iconic
shaman
who passed last year
i met king kumuwa at her shrine
in gangwa island where i witnessed her
last ritual
a celebration to bless
her 70th anniversary as a shaman
and to prepare her departure to the
spirit world
dating back to prehistoric times korean
shamanism has remained
a resilient form of spiritual practice
and a source of empowerment for many
women
this is jung-sun the shaman of the
people
during a ceremony that lasted several
days and nights
i remember bowing to her surrounded by
blades and colorful costumes and
offerings
everyday objects were being elevated
acquiring a new dimension right in front
of my eyes
i saw her becoming a god her body
through dance prayer and ritual
what's interesting is that despite their
position of power
korean shamans remain graceful humble
human beings through these women
i could clearly see the power within
ancient forms of knowledge
the role our cultures play in
maintaining a fragile
cosmic balance this is don ramon
a local healer from the center for
indigenous arts
in veracruz mexico where tottenham
culture
is being taught to future generations
the center's director umberto garcia
was proud describing an educational
model
where disciplines like art communication
or medicine are not independent but
entangled with each other totonat
cosmovision
revolves around this ever-changing
interconnected dimension there is a
natural rhythm that infuses every
activity here
be cooking or weaving or healing
nothing is trivial or decorative every
gesture
every action has a meaning these
traditions beliefs and rituals
they're far from being immobile they're
the result of
thousands of years of practice in a
painful regenerative process
these are unique pieces of wisdom we
must definitely
bring with us into the future and this
is what i'm doing
to make that happen i want to challenge
our current model of space colonization
and
i've decided to start with a big gesture
to recognize the moon as a universal
symbol
of rebirth and renewal
as part of the european space agency's
plans to support
a permanent human presence on the moon
i'm proposing to build
the moon temple a future space
for diverse cultural projections
traditions
and scientific research the moon temple
will stand on the rim of the shackleton
crater a gigantic
impact crater featuring peaks of eternal
light
and perpetual darkness it's design
takes advantage of lunar microgravity
the use of local resources
and the complex celestial mechanics that
operate on the south pole of the moon
sheltered in its interior we can find
traces from an intriguing new material
culture
a series of objects made with moon dust
and rare
aerospace materials symbolizing
humanity's ancestral wisdom and
all its complexity these
masks vessels and other ritual artifacts
they're powerful objects that imply deep
personal transformations sometimes even
becoming a bridge to distant worlds they
represent
the vast diversity embedded in the human
experience
these objects carry within them
thousands of stories
yet to be written some provide
protection
while others relate to the harsh
conditions that
people will endure inside our planet
but even if these objects come from a
place
far away from here we can still
recognize
a familiar human quality within them
the moon temple celebrates the moon as
the measure of
all things it is monument
to humanity's reason and imagination
it represents our chance to bring
together once again
science art and ritual
this might be a personal even
utopian vision for our interplanetary
future
but perhaps through these utopian
exercises
we can break free from many of our
prejudices
here on earth because we need more
diverse
personal narratives for our future
a future when we don't turn our backs to
our cultures
and the role they play in shaping who we
are today a future that does not
perpetuate
the survival of the most privileged at
the expense of the most vulnerable
but instead acknowledges our fragile
position
in this universe and our
responsibilities
towards it